so when we when we look at
um Twitter right and we say we can see
okay this is really hard
so here here's my my story about Twitter
it's a two-part story
um and it's all pre-elon musk ownership
so many years back somebody uh accused
me of horrible crimes on on Twitter and
I you know like anybody would I was like
you know I'm in the public eye people
say bad things I don't really you know I
brush it off whatever but I'm like this
is actually really bad like accusing me
of pedophilia like that's just not okay
so I thought I'm gonna report this so I
click report I report the tweet and
there's five others and every I'll go
through the process and then I get an
email it says you know whatever a couple
hours later saying uh thank you for your
report we're looking into this great
okay good then several hours further I
get an email back saying sorry we don't
see anything here to violate for terms
of use
okay so I emailed Jack and I say Jack
come on like this is ridiculous and he
emails back roughly saying
um yeah sorry Jimmy don't worry we'll
sort this out
and I just thought to myself you know
what
that's not the point right I'm Jimmy
Wales I Know Jack Dorsey I can email
Jack Dorsey he'll listen to me because
he's got an email from me and sorts it
out for me what about the teenager who's
being bullied uh and is getting abuse
right and getting accusations that
aren't true are they getting the same
kind of like really poor result in that
case so fast forward a few years
same thing happens
um the exact quote always goes
um please help me I'm only 10 years old
and Jimmy Wells raped me last week it's
like come on [__] off like that's
ridiculous so I report I'm like this
time I'm reporting but I'm thinking well
we'll see what happens this one gets
even worse because
then I get a same result email back
saying sorry we don't see any problems
so I raise it with other members of the
board who I know and Jack and like this
is really ridiculous like this is
outrageous
and some of the board members friends of
mine sympathetic and so good for them
but I actually got an email back then
from The General Counsel head of trust
and safety saying actually there's
nothing in this tweet that violates our
terms of service we don't regard uh and
and gave reference to the metoo movement
if we didn't allow accusations the metoo
movement it's an important thing and I
was like you know what actually if
someone says I'm 10 years old and
someone raped me last week I think the
advice should be here's the phone number
of the police like you need to get the
police involved it's not the place for
that accusation
so even back then by the way they did
delete those tweets but I mean the
rationale they gave spammy Behavior
right so completely separate from
abusing me it was just like oh well they
were retweeting too often okay whatever
so like that's just broken like that's a
system that it's not working for people
in the public eye I'm sure it's not
working for private people who get abuse
really horrible abuse can happen
so how is that today well it hasn't
happened to me
um since Elon took over but I don't see
why it couldn't and I suspect now if I
send a report and email someone there's
no one there to email me back because
he's gotten rid of a lot of the trust
and safety staff so I suspect that
problem is still really hard just
content moderation at huge scales have
huge scales is really something and I
don't know the full answer to this I
mean a piece of it could be
um you know to say actually making
specific allegations of crimes uh this
isn't the place to do that you know
we've got a huge database if you've got
an accusation of crime here's who's your
call the police the FBI whatever it is
it's not to be done in public and then
you do face really complicated questions
about metoo movement and people coming
forward in public and all of that but
it's again it's like probably you should
talk to a journalist right probably
there are better Avenues than just
tweeting uh from an account that was
created 10 days ago obviously set up to
abuse someone so I think they could do a
lot better
um but I also admit it's a hard problem
and there's also ways doing directly or
more humorously or more mocking way to
make the same kinds of accusations in
fact the accusations you mentioned if I
were to guess don't go that Viral
because they're not funny enough or
cutting enough but if you make it witty
and cutting and and uh meme it somehow
yeah yeah sometimes actually indirectly
that can go viral and they can destroy
reputations and yeah and you you get to
watch yourself
uh just all kinds of narratives takes
take hold yeah no I mean I remember
another uh case that didn't bother me
because it wasn't
of that nature but somebody was saying
you know I'm sure you you're making
millions off of Wikipedia I'm like no
actually I don't even work there I have
no salary
um and they're like you're lying I'm
gonna check your 990 form which is the
US form for
tax reporting for Charities
yeah I'm knocking here's the link go go
read it and you'll see I'm listed as a
board member and my salary is listed as
zero so
um you know so you know things like that
it's like okay that one that feels like
you're wrong but I can take that and I
can we can have that debate quite
quickly and again it didn't go viral
because it was kind of silly and if
anything would have gone viral it was me
responding but that's one where it's
like actually I'm happy to respond
because a lot of people don't know that
I don't work there and that I don't make
millions and I'm not a billionaire well
they must know that because it's in most
news media about me but uh the other one
I didn't respond to publicly because
it's like
Barbra Streisand effect you know it's
like sometimes calling attention to
someone who's abusing you who basically
has no followers and so on it's just a
waste and everything you describing now
is just something that all of us have to
kind of learn
um because everybody's in the public eye
I think uh when you have just two
followers and you get bullied by one of
the followers it hurts just as much as
we have a large number so it's not your
situation I think is echoed in the
situations of millions of other
especially teenagers and kids and so on
yeah I mean it's actually
um
an example uh so we don't generally use
my picture in the banners anymore on
Wikipedia but we did and then we did an
experiment one year where we tried other
people's pictures so one of our
developers
and you know one guy lovely very sweet
guy and he doesn't look like your
immediate thought of a nerdy Silicon
Valley developer he looks like a heavy
metal dude because he's cool and uh so
suddenly here he is with long hair and
tattoos and and there's there's his sort
of say here's what your money goes for
here's my my letter asking for sport and
he got massive abuse from Wikipedia like
calling him creepy and you know like
really massive
and this was being shown to 80 million
people a day his picture not the abuse
right the abuse was Elsewhere on the
internet
and he he was bothered by it and I
thought you know what there is a
difference I actually am in the public
eye yeah I get huge benefits from being
in the public eye I go around and make
public speeches if any random thing I
think of I can write and get it
published in the New York Times and you
know have this interesting life he's not
a public figure and so actually he
wasn't mad at us he wasn't you know it
was just like yeah actually suddenly
being thrust in the public eye and you
get suddenly lots of abuse which
normally I think you know if you're a
teenager and somebody in your class is
abusing you it's not going to go viral
so you're only gonna it's gonna be
hurtful because it's local and it's your
classmates or whatever
but when when sort of ordinary people go
viral in some abusive way it's really
really quite
tragic I don't know I mean even at a
small scale it feels viral when uh right
yeah five people your school and there's
a rumor and there's this feeling like
you're surrounded and nobody and the
feeling of loneliness I think
which you're speaking to when you don't
have a plat when you at least feel like
you don't have a platform to defend
yourself yeah and then this
powerlessness that I think a lot of
teenagers definitely feel and a lot of
people I think you're right and that I I
think even when just like two people
make up stuff about you or lie about you
or say mean things about your bully you
that can feel like a crowd but yeah yeah
that's a and it's a I mean whatever that
is in our genetics and our biology and
our the way our brain works it just can
be a terrifying experience and
um
somehow to correct that I mean I think
because everybody feels the pain of that
everybody suffers the pain that I think
will be forced to fix that as a society
to figure out a way around that I think
it's really hard to fix because I don't
think that problem isn't necessarily new
um you know someone
in High School who writes
graffiti that says Bucky has a [__] and
spreads a rumor about what Becky did
last weekend that's always been damaging
it's always been hurtful and that's uh
those kinds of attacks there's uh all
the time itself people see the internet